welcome to Cameron and Miliband live the
battle for number 10 tonight sees the
first big election test for two men one
of whom will be the UK's next prime
minister david cameron and Ed Miliband
are the only people with a genuine
chance of forming the next government
night let's see what they're made of
oh that's a tricky one to start with but
I'd say two things about what David
Cameron position as Prime Minister which
I admire calling week and despicable
didn't you have previously killed in the
chicken and a bully but you know he took
a risk in the Conservative Party we do
sometimes in the House of Commons use
phrases that perhaps after as we think
patches a bit over the proper I want to
sustain the EU Veronica and as you say
it's not my priority to have a
referendum but I think Britain is at its
best when we're out there trading and
cooperating and working with others in
the world said earlier it is hard to
avoid the backing fear not that's not
the question the question is well it's
the question that mask like sploagies
well you're gonna tell them no no no let
me finish the point you if people need
to know that sort of thing does that
David Cameron relative no it was it have
you ever had three shredded wheat have I
ever had free show I have actually I
think I can then we have borrowed a lot
of money hell yes I'm tough in there
right think politicians do have a date
by which they need to say well I think
it's time for someone else to take over
would you believe we're out of time
we're out of time already already you
okay okay you're right yeah did you
enjoy that well it was quite fun yes